I come to this video playing xaashi am
so she has this Egypt yes Egypt I got
one right let's see Kings Indian comfort
our Kings Indian let's go for the h3
line still early in the morning I don't
mind it would like to play the somewhat
dull exchange line I can play The
Sharper once more when i'm more awake
now you're getting it yeah Rookie of a
dozen own an online mostly in the
regular exchange one point is that after
move like a 4 here takes Bishop takes
its no pin so a 4 is not making any
sense i think a 3 is right this is a
long theoretical line and this guy is
just playing it like it's doing that
every day mm-hmm maybe he is maybe some
some guy is playing in the exchange
against him all the time and you just
know that by heart I really I really
don't know it so well to be honest mmm
yeah Bishop here and I don't know i mean
probably i need to go down Black has
sacrificed the pawn but he's very active
takes Bishop takes Bishop takes ed I
don't know II for mmm looks looks like
looks fine for black yeah i don't i
don't know this line i know that it is
that it is existing i don't know any
details hmm yeah probably not not much
choice here one usually one advantage of
them of the exchange is that people
don't know it really they know it away
this is harmless I don't need to study
that and then they play a quite often
some sub power line and then you really
get something despite the simplified
nature of the position but well he just
played everything instantly I know he is
thinking at least what to do Bishop
Bishop here probably am and then d 6
oops
I didn't consider that one at all maybe
it's no problem but a bit embarrassing
night here and the six I can go to see
5m yeah maybe I always have t6
complicated stuff I mean I actually
believe it it looks good for for for
white when I keep the deep one cannot be
too bad I have no tactic here right the
move like Knight f6 is not good jum no
probably not I need to keep the deep on
this is just a great pawn taking King
takes I can give this check but it's not
the end of the world at least I don't
see anything to grade the question is
what what am i doing now should I just
castle here maybe eat uru p1 when I
cannot take I have night c5 this is the
most forceful move
probably just attacking this
I'm not sure I really want to want to
Castle I mean here the East e2 as well
oke to rookie one maybe maybe castles
was easier getting the look into play
and get rid of this irritating porn
quickly I know I could at least
theoretically speaking take it or castle
now come on come I want to I want to get
get out of there okay it takes takes
Bishop takes with the exchange for him
a very tricky the smooth what should i
do I don't I don't know really
yeah very tricky this is some supporting
the deep on if he takes King f1 this is
hanging and I'm pushing this hang soon
rookie three I can also just play rookie
to Arab situ I mean
maybe I can simply play night you for
and take that I mean maybe okay well d7d
seven takes rook takes look a one check
is very very very very important trick I
just I just do what I what I just said
get this pawn back by simple means I
know I'm not I'm threatening Knight f6
though yeah this was public enemy number
one this this piss porn and I got it I
might know like to prevent the simple
exchange second
I thought this one was good night c 5
hmm ok at the entire rookie one check f1
night takes its winning a PCM Luke a
three-book takes III black resigns Wow
yeah this was to us 10 so in here he put
up some really dangerous play and maybe
black boss hoss good tre this is this is
Sir I don't know maybe a theoretical
position something like that it's a
theoretical position but favor how time
to understand really what is quoting on
its it's sharp 3d sharp now the computer
is just giving why the big edge but this
is this type of player is known I don't
know exactly the exact position but ah
wait isn't this I wonder isn't it
something with night a six at some point
I don't know this is also known camp for
the deep all he does not get it back
okay okay this is a big mistake
according to the computer ah ok
yeah okay this is a somehow a typical
computer move that it's hard for a human
sometimes to consider night be one it's
not it's not difficult really but i will
look that it's a double attack both
rooks are hanging actually capture just
this one and white wins in exchange so
as simple as that it's still a bit
tricky in the position but still it's an
exchange and this is not really on
Knight f6 seems to be good okay yeah
here I just wanted to castle but it
seems that I'm keeping check keeping an
edge now are here here i miss Rooke a
one rook a one is better ok this is also
winning according to the computer in the
game it does not feel like that it still
feel shaky complicated whatever because
you always have this this pawn you know
I overlooked Knight f6 here because I
wanted to get this bond so badly it's
not bad i really i think I mean I df6 is
better obviously but the Sun should keep
something this is the blunder d 7 is
better yeah I missed this check here I
missed the check and then promoting ok
this and now we can play f4 and this
seems to be okay according to the
computer age / what this should be good
but it somehow isn't i-93 yupz oops okay
yeah this this was neat that this losers
I mean
he can play rook III and stop be
completely in the game yeah it's just
very complicated so it's amazingly
complicated for the exchange Kings in
yet but sometimes it happens that piece
play gets a tricky yeah thanks for
watching